what we have here in hand is lenovo's
rollable concept mobile phone with the
touch of a button the phone can go from
5 inches to 6.5 inches or maybe it's
just happy to see us handling it jokes
aside the phone actually has a good
amount of usability considerations which
is surprising in a concept phone one you
just saw is the phone screen
automatically expanding itself once I
hit the compose button this is great
because you don't have to Grapple with
sharing that screen space with the
keyboard the front facing camera is
actually hidden way behind the screen
and will only reveal itself once the
selfie button is hit and if you're a fan
of watching YouTube videos the screen
will expand itself once again into a
21x9 ratio for the best viewing
experience automatically with most of
the hype with mobile phones going
towards foldable phones instead this
rollable concept is actually a purple
fresh air I think it really looks fancy
in hand and I'll be looking forward to
see if Lenovo brings it to the market
[Music]